et je savais que ce jour arriverait. Mais je ne l'attendais pas
à ses sept ans. Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Bref, je lui ai demandé : "Et qu'est-ce que tu en as pensé ?"
Donc elle a commencé à me raconter, et tous ceux
qui sont parents ici reconnaitront le jeu du business loto.
Donc les bateaux partent d'Angleterre, descendent
jusqu’en Afrique, traversent l'océan...
c'est là le Passage du Milieu, ils arrivent en Amérique
où les esclaves sont vendus, me dit-elle.
Mais Abraham Lincoln est élu président,
il fait la proclamation d'indépendance et ils sont libres.
Et après 10 secondes.
"Je peux aller jouer, maman ?"
Et je me suis dit : "C'est tout ?" Enfin quoi,
c'est le Passage du Milieu, un événement
extrêmement significatif et pour elle, c'est un peu comme si
des noirs étaient partis en croisière, voilà en gros
ce qu'elle avait compris. (Rires)
Moi, je voulais vraiment qu'elle comprenne ça,
donc quand elle m'a demandé si elle pouvait aller jouer, j'ai dit :
"Oui". (Rires)
J'avais toutes ces petites pièces.
Je développe des jeux donc j'ai ce genre de choses chez moi.
J'ai dit: "Oui, tu peux aller jouer" et je lui ai donné
quelques pièces et lui ai dit de les peindre
en plusieurs familles. Voici des photos de Maezza
quand elle... mon Dieu, je suis toujours émue en les voyant.
Donc elle peint ses petites familles.
J'en attrape quelques-unes et je les mets dans un bateau.
Voici le bateau. J'ai pas passé beaucoup de temps dessus comme vous voyez.
Donc en gros pour résumer, j'ai attrapé ces familles,
et elle me dit : " Maman, tu as oublié le bébé rose,
et le papa bleu,
et tu as oublié tout ça."
Et elle dit : "Ils veulent y aller". Et j'ai répondu :
"Non, chéri, ils ne veulent pas. C'est le Passage du Milieu.
"Personne ne veut aller par le Passage du Milieu."
Donc elle m'a lancé un regard que seule une fille
de développeuse de jeux peut lancer à sa mère,
et pendant qu'on traverse l'océan, en suivant ces règles,
elle réalise que les vagues sont très hautes et elle me dit :
"On va pas y arriver."
Et elle réalise aussi qu'on a pas assez de nourriture,
et elle me demande quoi faire, et je réponds :
"On peut soit.. Rappelez-vous qu'elle a sept ans...
"On peut mettre des gens dans l'eau
ou espérer que personne ne tombe malade
et qu'on arrive de l'autre côté."
Et elle... le regard qu'elle avait quand elle est venue
et elle a dit... c'était après un mois
avoir étudié l'histoire des noirs à l'école.
Après un mois, elle me dit :
"Est-ce que ça s'est vraiment passé ?"
Et je réponds : "Oui." Et elle dit : " Donc si
Donc si j'étais sortie des bois... voici son frère et sa sœur...
"Si j'étais sortie, Avalon et Donovan, auraient pu, eux, être partis." "Oui."
"Mais je pourrais les revoir en Amérique." "Non."
"Mais si je les revoyais, on pourrait rester ensemble ?" "Non."
"Donc papa pourrait être parti." "Oui."
Elle est restée fascinée puis s'est mise à pleurer,
et je me suis mise à pleurer, et son père pleurait aussi,
et on pleurait tous. Il ne s'attendait pas vraiment
à rentrer chez lui en plein Passage du Milieu,
mais bon c'est arrivé. (Rires)
Et donc, on a fait ce jeu, et elle a compris.
Elle a compris car elle a passé du temps avec ces gens.
Ce n'était pas un truc abstrait dans une brochure ou dans un film.
Et donc ça a été une expérience très forte.
Voici le jeu que j'ai fini par appeler
"le Nouveau Monde", parce que ça sonnait bien.
Je crois pas que ce nouveau monde ait semblé vraiment excitant
aux gens qui y ont été amenés comme esclaves.
Mais quand c'est arrivé, j'ai vu la terre entière.
J'étais si excitée. Je développe des jeux
depuis 20 ans et là je décidais de m'y remettre.
Ma famille est irlandaise.
Voici un jeu appelé "Síochán Leat." " Que la paix soit avec vous."
C'est toute l'histoire de ma famille en un seul jeu.
J'en ai fait un autre appelé "Train".
J'ai fait une série de six jeux
parlant de sujets difficiles, et tant qu'à faire ça,
en voici un dont on doit parler,
je vous laisse deviner de quoi il s'agit tout seuls.
J'ai aussi fait un jeu sur la Piste des Larmes.
En voici un avec 50 000 pièces individuelles.
J'étais folle de commencer ça,
mais j'en suis au milieu maintenant.
C'est la même chose.
J'espère enseigner l’histoire à travers ces jeux.
Et voici celui sur lequel je travaille en ce moment, qui est...
je suis en plein dedans et je sais pas pourquoi mais ça m'émeut beaucoup...
c'est un jeu appelé "les employés de cuisine mexicains."
Au début, c'était plus ou moins un problème de maths.
Comme si on montrait les chiffres de l'immigration illégale.
Mais plus j'en apprenais sur la culture mexicaine...
mon associé est Mexicain. plus je découvrais
que pour nous tous la nourriture est un besoin essentiel
tout comme pour les Mexicains, mais c'est aussi beaucoup plus que cela.
C'est un moyen d'exprimer l'amour. C'est un moyen d'exprimer...
Mon Dieu, je suis beaucoup plus émue que ce que je pensais.
Je vais arrêter de regarder cette photo.
C'est le moyen d'exprimer la beauté. C'est leur façon de vous dire qu'ils vous aiment,
que vous êtes important pour eux et vous entendrez toujours
quelqu'un parler de sa grand-mère mexicaine
avec le mot "nourriture" dès la première phrase.
Pour moi, cette magnifique culture, cette magnifique façon de s'exprimer,
c'est ce que je veux mettre dans mes jeux.
Les jeux, pour changer, transforment notre façon de voir ces sujets,
notre façon de voir ces gens
dont il est question, et nous transforment.
On évolue à travers les jeux,
parce qu'on s'y implique, on y joue
et on y apprend des choses. Merci. (Applaudissements)